المترجم: Sarah Saad
المدقّق: Abdulaziz Al-wandawi
اليوم بإذن الله دوري الحقيقي هو إقناعكم
فعلاً بأن الكرسي الذي يجلس عليه كل واحد
هو كرسي قاتل!
وأن هذا الكرسي ليس الصديق الودود،
إنما العدو اللدود.
وهناك فرق!
أريد أن آخذكم معي
في رحلة إلى استراليا!
من يرغب في الذهاب؟
الجميع، أنا عارف.
قضيت سبع سنوات في استراليا
في هذه الجامعة.
لكن دعوني أخبركم بما حدث
في أول شهرين من الجامعة.
هذا مكتبي!
إن أردت أن أطبع ورقة واحدة
أعطي أمر الطباعة
ثم أضطر أن أخرج من المكتب
أخرج من المبنى بالكامل
أذهب إلى مبنى آخر
في داخل المبنى توجد
غرفة خاصة بالتصوير والطباعة
آخذ الورقة وأرجع مرة ثانية
إلى مكتبي غاضبا!
لماذا لا توجد عندي طابعة؟
أنا طالب دراسات عليا! طالب دكتوراه!
أنا مبعوث!
أريد طابعة!
لا يمكن!
هذه جامعة فقيرة!
تعرفون السعودي عندما يتضايق!
فورا خطاب إلى رئيس القسم،
خطاب إلى مشرفي
أريد طابعة!
معي خمسة استراليين يدرسون الدكتوراه
في نفس الغرفة ليس لديهم إشكالية!
كانوا يقولون لي
"يامحمد، هذا جيد لصحتك!"
أنت تبذل طاقة،
تترك الكرسي.
قلت لهم: لاتكلموني عن الصحة!
قولوا لي كيف أستطيع
الحصول على طابعة!
أريد طابعة!
أحضروا لي طابعة،
وفرحت.
لكن بعد فترة
أصابتني آلام في أسفل الظهر
من كثرة الجلوس
ولم أكتشف
ولم أكتشف حقيقة
أن السبب الحقيقي
هو الكرسي!
كلنا نعلم خطورة المخدرات
رقم واحد.
اثنين،
التدخين.
ثلاثة،
الكحول.
أربعة،
هو الكرسي الذي نجلس عليه الآن!
ونجلس عليه قبل وبعد
وفي كل وقت.
أصبحنا نجلس في كل مكان.
لو تتبعنا تاريخ البشرية
من رجل الكهف
مروراً بالعصر الزراعي
العصر الصناعي
لم يجلس الإنسان تماماً
لم يجلس الإنسان
إلا في العصر الحالي.
عصر الكمبيوتر، الانترنت
و الجوال.
أصبحنا نجلس في كل مكان.
أصبح التدخين...
ليس هو الخطير.
بل أصبح الجلوس
أخطر من التدخين.
نعم،
بل يقال أن الجلوس الطويل
هو التدخين الجديد
في عصرنا الحالي.
مصيبة!
لماذا؟
لأن هناك أمراض عديدة
مرتبطة بالجلوس.
هذا هو اسمها
هذا هو اسمها العلمي الطبي
(siting disease).
أمراض القلب، هشاشة العظام، السمنة
الموت المبكر
داء السكري، ضغط الدم.
هل أعدد آكثر؟
هناك أكثر من ثلاثين، أربعين مرض
مرتبط بالجلوس.
لا أستطيع أن أذكرها لكم
وإلا انتهى الـيوم بالكامل.
الآن لو تعشينا الليلة
عشاءا دسما.
بمعنى دهون و سكريات.
يعني اليوم المفتوح في الطعام.
هل سنصاب بالسمنة غدا؟
طبعاً لا، لن نصب بالسمنة.
لكن إن كنا في سلوكنا الغذائي
السيء هذا
مستمرون فيه كل يوم
لمدة سنة، سنتين، ثلاثة... عشر سنوات.
من المؤكد بأننا سوف نصاب بالسمنة
لأن هذا سلوك.
كذلك الحال مع الجلوس.
لو جلسنا أربعة وعشرين ساعة
على الكرسي
لن نصب بإحدى الأمراض
المتعلقة بالجلوس أبداً.
لكن إن كان سلوكنا خامل
ونجلس كل يوم
سنة، سنتين، ثلاثة
خمسة، عشر سنوات
من المؤكد بعد ذلك أننا سنصاب بواحد
على الأقل، من الأمراض المرتبطة بالجلوس.
فلا ننتظر هذا اليوم.
لنا ثمانية سنوات
لم نتأهل إلى كأس العالم في كرة القدم.
صحيح؟
لكن المملكة العربية السعودية، تحتل المركز
الثالث عالميا في الخمول البدني.
هذا تقرير نشر في مجلة (Lancet)
أشهر المجلات الطبية على مستوى العالم.
للأسف، تأتي المملكة العربية السعودية أولا
في ضغط الدم والسمنة والسكري وهشاشة العظام.
هذه الأمراض .. ماذا نسميها؟
أمراض الجلوس.
نجلس في البيت، في الجامعة،
في السيارة وفي المدرسة.
حتى في الملعب، 22 لاعب في الملعب
يشاهدهم أكثر من 60.000 متفرج!
ناهيك عن ملايين المشاهدين
خلف شاشة التلفاز!
نشاهد ولا نمارس!
أي عصر هذا؟!
هذه التوصية العلمية
إخواني أخواتي
عشرين سنة و أنا أقولها
عشرون سنة،
هذه التوصية العلمية الطبية تقول
على كل شخص ممارسة ثلاثين دقيقة
من النشاط البدني للوقاية من أمراض القلب.
حقيقة، تغير الوضع.
الدراسات العلمية التي جرت قبل سنتين
أو ثلاثة تقول أن هذا لايكفي
للوقاية من أمراض القلب.
السؤال الحقيقي
ما الذي تفعله بقية اليوم؟
ثلاثين دقيقة فقط و تجلس لبقية اليوم! لا
فإذا... قضينا... وقتنا
في الجلوس أمام التلفاز.
أمام الأنترنيت.
أمام الأجهزة الإلكترونية.
بغض النظر فإننا إن
مارسنا النشاط البدني أو لم نمارسه.
فنحن معرضون للإصابة بأمراض القلب،
و هذه مصيبة.
هل تتوقعون فقط أن عامة الناس
سلوكهم خامل ؟
لا و الله.
هذه دراسة أجريناها العام الماضي
على لاعبي كرة القدم
في إحدى أندية العاصمة (الرياض).
تم نشرها في إحدى المؤتمرات العالمية
في(سانتياغو - أمريكا).
لنرى نسبة الخمول البدني
لدى اللاعبين
77 في المئة منهم خاملين
يقضون بقية اليوم
في مشاهدة التلفاز وعلى الإنترنيت
على الجوال وعلى الألعاب الإلكترونية.
إذا الخمول البدني منتشر عند عامة الناس
وحتى عند الرياضيين، و هذه مشكلة.
أرعبتنا يا دكتور خوفتنا.
حقيقة يجب أن نخاف.
لكن الأخبار السارة
أن الحل سهل جدا.
الحل محتاج إلى تغيير بسيط
في حياتنا.
هذه القاعدة أسميها
قاعدة "الحياة الصحية والنشطة".
نغير سلوكنا
8 + 1 + 15
يساوي كم؟
ما الذي نقصده بـ24 ؟
24 ساعة
كل واحد موجود هنا لديه 24 ساعة.
حتى أنت 24 مو 23
تؤشر لي قائلا: لا.
خلينا نقسمها - كنت أمزح معه -
خلينا نقسم الـ 24 ساعة
ثمانية ساعات نوم في الليل
في الليل وليس النهار
ثمانية ساعات النوم سلوك صحي
و ليس سلوك خامل
ساعة من ممارسة النشاط البدني
أي نشاط بدني مهما كان
مشي أو هرولة أو ركوب دراجة أو سباحة.
أي نشاط أنت تعشقه
وتستطيع أن تمارسه يوميا.
هذا ممتاز.
بقية اليوم، بقية الـ 24 ساعة.
لدينا 15 ساعة ما الذي نفعله فيها؟
هذا هو سلوك الحياة النشط.
يجب أن نقلل من عدد ساعات الجلوس
يجب أن نقطع عدد ساعات الجلوس
يجب أن نقلل من الوقت الذي نستخدمه
في الإنترنت والجوال والألعاب الإلكترونية.
يجب أن نزيد من الأنشطة
البدنية اليومية الحياتية.
مثل: صعود الدرج المشي للمسجد
المشي في الجامعة المشي في المدرسة
أعمال البيت الأعمال المنزلية
خاصة القسم هذا ممتاز.
تنظيف الأرضيات تنظيف الجدران
تنظيف المطبخ، العمل في حديقة المنزل.
هذه تصرف طاقة عالية جدا
و مهمة جدا.
يكفي تركيزنا على هذه المنطقة.
هذه لم تخلق -هذه المنطقة-
لكي نجلس عليها.
يجب أن ننتقل من هذا التركيز
من هذا المربع الأعلى إلى ... الأسفل.
يجب أن نستخدم القدمين.
فيزيولوجيا و تشريحيا.
الله سبحانه و تعالى خلق القدمين
للمشي، للحركة و للوقوف.
إخواني أخواتي، الخمول البدني
سلوك.
الطفل المدخن
سيصبح رجلا مدخنا في المستقبل.
الطفل المصاب بالسمنة
سيكون رجلا مصابا بالسمنة.
كذلك الحال مع الخمول البدني.
الطفل الخامل و الذي يكثر من الجلوس
سيصبح رجلا خاملا
و يكثر من الجلوس في المستقبل.
يجب أن نغير حياتنا
ونغير بيئتنا.
البيئة النشطة ستساعدنا.
بيئة في البيت في المدرسة
في الجامعة في العمل في أي مكان.
يجب أن نغير هذه البيئة.
كيف يا دكتور؟
هذه نماذج غربية الآن.
البعض تخلص
من الطاولة المستديرة
و أصبخ يعطينا اجتماعات عمل أثناء المشي
"walk and talk meeting"
لماذا؟
الإيتكار، الإبداع، واتخاد القرارات الصائبة
أفضل أثناء المشي منها أثناء الجلوس.
أتريدون دليلا علميا؟
سأعطيكم دليلا علميا.
الآن ، هنا على اليسار
شكل الدماغ بعد الجلوس لفترة.
الآن، لنقارن الدماغ بعد المشي
لمدة عشرين دقيقة.
شاهدوا اللون الأخضر و الأحمر والأصفر.
هذا دليل على زيادة نشاط
الخلايا الدماغية.
إذا، الإبداع و اتخاد القرارات الصائبة
والرائعة أثناء المشي.
أفضل منها أثناء الجلوس
الإختبارات قادنة، من يريد المذاكرة
يذاكر أثناء المشي، وإلا سينام وهو جالس.
نصيحة.
البعض تخلص من المكاتب التقليدية
والتي نسميها المكاتب الخاملة.
هذ الذي أمامكم
مكتب نشط.
سير متنحرك مرتبط بهذا المكتب
أمامه الكمبيوتر
يستطيع الشخص أن يجلس 8 ساعات
من خلال المشي البطيء.
أيضا هناك دراجة ثابتة مرتبطة
بهذا المكتب النشط.
بعض المدارس، إحواني وأخواتي
تخلصوا من الكراسي واستبدلوها بكرات طبية.
هذه الكرات الطبية تحتاج إلى توازن.
هذا التوازن يجعل معظم عضلات الظهر والبطن
والقدمين تعمل طوال الوقت فتصرف طاقة.
هذه مكتبة في إحدى الجامعات
ايضا استبدلت الكراسي بكرات طبية.
بل أن هناك مدارس في الغرب
بلا كراسي بالكامل.
مدارس بالكامل
بلا كراسي.
الطلاب يستطيعون أن يأخذوا الحصة
الدراسية في وضع الوقوف.
هؤلاء الطلاب
طلاب صغار.
الآن، هذا هو دوركم.
هذا دوركم وأنتم جالسون.
إن لم تقتنعوا بالدراسات العلمية...
ممكن أسأل الجميع الآن، رجالا ونساءا
فضلا لا أمرا.
أن تقفوا لما تبقى من وقت خطابي
ولاحظوا الفرق.
ممكن أسألكم أن تقفوا، لو سمحتم.
نعم الجميع، نعم الجميع.
أفضل منظر رأيته في حياتي لا أدري كم العدد
فأنا لا أرى نهاية الجانبين.
ما شاء الله
تبارك الله.
حسنا
أعطيتكم الآن النماذج الغربية
هل نستطيع كسعوديين
أن نغير من طبيعتنا؟
من هذا الذي في الصورة؟
هذا سعودي، هذا أنا لابس عقال
لأثبت لكم أني سعودي أستطيع أن أغير.
هذا مكتبي في جامعة (الملك سعود)
بلا كرسي.
بل محاضراتي أعطيها
من وضع الوقوف.
(تصفيق)
طلابي أيضا يأخذون المحاضرة
من وضع الوقوف.
لو كانوا موجودين هنا
لأثبتوا هذا الشيء.
هذا مكتبي الآن في البيت.
طبعا لا يوجد كرسي
كما ترون السير المتحرك.
الآن أنا أعمل 8 ساعات
بسرعة منخفضة أقل من 2كم/ ساعة.
أنا انسان نشط.
هذا مكتبي في البيت
وهذا السير لا يكلفني 1000 ريال.
بتغيير بسيط
يمكنني أن أصبح نشطا.
(تصفيق)
أبت ابنتي الصغيرة
في الصف الأول الابتدائي
إلا أن تثبت للجميع
استطاعتها التخلص من الكرسي القاتل
وتستطيع العمل على الكمبيوتر
من وضع الوقوف أيضا.
(تصفيق)
دائما نتسائل
دائما نتسائل لماذا البعض منا
من الخامليين
يأكلون أكثر منا ولا يصابون بالسمنة؟
هذا يأكل اكله مساءا ودائما نحيف
وأنا لو أشم رائحة الطعام يزداد وزني؟
مالذي يجعل هؤلاء نحفاء
دون أن يمارسوا أي مجهود بدني؟
هذه المجلة (SCIENCE) من أفضل المجلات
الطبية العالمية، تجيب على هذا السؤال.
يحثت عن مجموعة خاملة جدا.
قسمتهم على مجموعتين
مجموعة البدناء، هذا طبيعي.
خمول بدني
يصاب بالبدانة.
لكن الغير الطبيعي
المجموعة الثانية
غير البدناء (النحفاء).
كلهم خاملين جدا.
قاست الأنشطة البدنية اليومية الحياتية
كل حركة يقوم بها جسم الإنسان
لمدة 10 أيام متواصلة
بأجهزة دقيقة جدا.
هذه النتيجة الآن
أمامكم.
وقت الجلوس، و وقت الوقوف.
وقت الجلوس بالأبيض والوقوف بالأخضر.
لا حظوا أن البدناء يجلسون أكثر.
لكن غير البدناء يقفون أكثر مثلكم.
حسنا، ماذا فعلت الدراسة أيضا؟
قاست الفرق
فرق طاقة الوقوف بين البدين وغير البدين.
وجدت أن هذه الطاقة 352 سعرة حرارية
في اليوم الواحدن فقط من الوقوف.
هل هذه الطاقة، السعرات الحرارية
مرتفعة أم منخفضة؟
دعونا نحولها الآن
إلى نشاط بدني.
هذه تعادل الـ352 سعرة حرارية
تعادل جري 42 دقيقة في اليوم.
أو مشي لدة 72 دقيقة في اليوم
يعني ساعة و12 دقيقة.
خلصت هذه الدراسة إلى التالي
طاقة الوقوف جعلت النحيف نحيفا
بالرعم من خموله البدني.
دائما أتسائل
والله يحيرني هذا السؤال
لماذا العاملة المنزلية نحيلة
إن قارناها بشيء آخر؟
لكن ليس هذا الحال فقط لدى النساء
بل حتى الرجال.
فعندما أرى السائق وأقارنه بالرجل
بعض الأمور تقدمت وتأخرت أخرى
فطار صوابي
السمنة منتشرة في كل مكان.
لعلي أخيرا أذكر نفسي وأذكر أخواتي وإخواني
بقاعدة سلوك الحياة الصحي النشط.
نعم تستطيع التغيير.
نعم تستطيعين التغيير.
نعم، جميعنا نستطيع تغيير سلوكنا
الخامل إلى سلوك نشط.
ونطبق قاعدة
سلوك الحياة الصحي والنشط.
ثمان ساعات من النوم وساعة من النشاط البدني
و 15 ساعة علينا أن نقضيها في سلوك نشط جدا.
شكرا لكم
شكرا TEDx الرياض.
(تصفيق)